[Music]
One Path Network. I mean, you guys would
have known who they are already. They do
a fantastic job in terms of
disseminating some of the most high
quality daer videos on the internet in
the English language. They have now
actually produced an app. Now, I know in
this Ramadan you're going to want to
take advantage of that. I've already
taken advantage of that and browse
through the app and it's an amazing app.
I'm sure you're going to be downloading
it right now. The link is in the
description.
How are you guys doing today? Inshallah,
we're going to be tackling a very
important topic which relates to using
philosophy, using logic, using mantik,
which is the Arabic for logic. we're
using calam in da'wah and uh in
particular because some
ultra-conservative scripturalists they
say that this uh is something we
shouldn't use because the salaf the
pious predecessors they they dispraed it
in its entirety or that there's
something that we should not even touch
and um that we should just stick to the
Quran and to the sunnah and obviously we
believe in the Quran and we believe in
sticking to the Quran and sunnah have
you heard this rhetoric Ali
I do and and I think a lot of times it's
made me feel like sometimes guilty in my
da to like okay you know what
am I doing something wrong and it's even
though you dismiss these kind of things
but it really does put this thing in the
back of your head like okay you know am
I doing something wrong here by using
this argument for example the
contingency argument uh or you know the
variety of arguments that we use you
know it's like okay am I doing something
wrong and that's problematic on it own
why do I have to feel like in my da for
example like and and anybody's da I'm
not talking myself. Yeah, people out
there, the brothers out there who are
going and doing da'ah, why should they
even feel like that? Because there have
been statements made of you know you
know these people use calam and you know
know philosophers and they always they
hostile and I'm like okay you're fellow
brothers I don't understand like for
example if one of your children had a
shabbah and was on the verge of leaving
Islam you might come to one of these
brothers that you actually have a
problem with and ask him to use some
mant some logical ways of answering. So
the thing is um I believe in that aspect
it's sad that this is happening but I
would actually want you to clarify to me
because it seems like what they're
saying is actually you know it's not
correct you know actually I'm not going
to say they're misinforming but maybe
they misinformed themselves maybe so
maybe if you can bring light to a hijab
we do use these arguments in our da
are we right are we wrong
yes so basically I think what's
happening here is there's something
called the fallacy of equivocation right
so the fallacy of equivocation is where
we use the same word
and it means something different, but
we're using it to mean the same thing,
okay?
To to to talk about the same thing, and
we're not talking about the same thing.
And Sabor uses this very good example.
For example, if someone is lying on the
floor and he needs uh medical assistance
and he says, "Can a can a doctor come
and help me?" He's not talking about a
professor of history or something. He's
talking about a medical doctor even
though the two words are the same.
Right.
But it's like it's like saying, "I drink
I drank a beer, ginger beer."
Yes. Yes. Yeah. Good. Good. Yeah. So,
it's the fallacy of a and I'll prove to
you that it's the fallacy of a
Christian. One of the things that they
bring forward is it's not just one
isolated quote. It's many of the quotes
of the salaf.
But one very famous one is a when he
says
you know that
well when when I hear heard that hijab
I'll be honest with you. It's like I'm
thinking if I imafi was seeing our dawa
he he would beat us up with the shoe. Is
that the case?
It's not. Let me explain. Forget about
me. We're not going to talk about what I
believe and what you believe. We're
going to bring the today. Right. But
before we do this, it's so important to
realize and to be able to historically
contextualize everything that we're
talking about as it's understood by
philosophers by the mazelites and those
kinds of things but also it's something
which is despite all of those people as
well like in other words uses a kind of
we'll come to this right
but
this is a time of shi
wasn't born you know you know ashari
school couldn't have been what is being
referenced here in its entirety or proto
martesilism was there
whilst and those kind of individuals but
it wasn't actual martialism
okay
so this is not what is being referred to
and I'll explain to you forget about
what I say let's see what and we'll put
it on the screen has to say about this
okay
he says he said this is when the
predecessors dispraam dialectic theology
saying statements like these are
irreligious heretics right
and this is one other thing that's
attributed to
that you know whoever goes into he
becomes a heretic.
So he says and none went down the path
of calam and it succeeded. This is
speaking right?
He says they were not referring to calam
as a whole.
You see it's all being it's all being
shown I think you're not plagiarizing
I'm not speaking no all the references
are there. Look it's in Arabic and
English. You can see both right. Rather,
their comments were to make note of a
common reality regarding those who speak
about religion in a way that is averse
to the messengers. Now, one may say this
is a segmented uh quote is something
which is one off. No problem. We'll
we'll ask we'll put another quote. It's
on the it's on the screen right now.
Everyone can see in English and Arabic.
The Salaf did not deem the essence of
kalam blameworthy.
Okay.
For every human being ultimately
practices it.
Or is there more? Yeah. They did not
dispraise intellectual rigor, deep
thought, and argumentation. All of which
Allah commanded his messenger to
practice. Subhan Allah. He's making it a
thing that Allah he told the messenger
to to do. They did not rebuke using what
Allah and his messenger clarified as
intellectual evidence. Furthermore, they
did not even rebuke calam that is true.
So here he's if he's saying this,
so there aream that is true.
And there's that is false.
Okay. Yeah. I was going to say if there
is calam that is true, it necessitates
that kalam that's false.
That's right. It's not all the same,
right? So, which one is true? Which one
is false? They only rebuke falseam. So,
he's going to tell us which one is
false.
That is antithetical, meaning opposed to
the Quran and Sunnah. That's the one
that's false. Which is antithetical to
the Quran.
And contrary to sound reason, the
latter, this type of calam is falsehood.
Okay.
The calam dispraised by the salaf is the
false that is opposed to the law and
intellect. Meaning here what this is
clear view. He says that doesn't even
say that the sound will never heard.
Yeah. It will go it will never go
against because a sound because we're
not talking about those they've been
distorted by all kinds of ideas. Just
talking about sound will never go
against.
Yeah. An actual rational argument which
with sound premises and sound valid and
sound premises. It can never go against.
This is his position. That's why he
wrote a book called
that the lack of contradiction or
antithetical relationship between the
and the intellect and this is the name
of his book right
let's put forget let's maybe maybe
they'll say well you're talking about
calam but you brothers use philosophy he
actually uses there's one about him
talking about philosophy as well as for
refuting look it's on the screen okay
as for refuting or accepting all of
philosophy then this is impossible
repeat that again one more time
one more time for people to see.
As for refuting or accepting all of
philosophy, then this is impossible.
There is not a single thing which
philosophers unanimously champion.
Yeah.
Nor a position which they agree upon.
This is true in all of theology,
esquetology and prophecy as well as
natural sciences and mathematics. By the
way, this shows you this shows you that
they consider the natural even considers
maths and natural sciences as part of
philosophy.
Yeah.
So the danger the imagine the danger now
we've done a video already talking about
this guy now Degrasse Tyson talking
about look at look at the misconception
but we have people ultra scripturalists
ultra-conservative scripturists in our
own camp
who are saying the same things they
don't realize the entailments of what
they're saying
natural in this country and in the west
in general and not only that but even in
Iban Tamia's time right he died in 728
ah
they considered
as they would call it natural philosophy
Yeah, he they actually refer to it in
that sense. Natural philosophy is
science.
If you say philosophy is haram, are you
saying that chemistry is haram? Are you
saying that biology is haram? Are you
saying that physics is haram? The
prophet told us
he said that whoever acts like a doctor
and he's not actually a doctor and he
harms somebody then he's responsible.
Meaning what? Meaning there's there's
actual doctors. But if
or if medicine is something which is to
be practiced then you need the
philosophy of science. You need to know
how to do induction and verification. So
these guys when they say philosophy is
haram wall they are they are ignorant
for so they are ignorant for so I cannot
imagine
either either either they're
misinforming people on purpose or
they're themselves misinformed. They
don't know because what they do is they
read the calam of the Salaf and they
think oh the word calam is here
that must mean it's talking about it's
talking about the same calam that we use
or that
well well there's a fine example that we
mentioned well we mentioned before the
video is for example when
and you don't know the historical
context you're going to make big big
errors look what says here this is in
his book
actually this is one of the last books I
think it might have even been the last
book he's ever produced before he died
listen to what he says and this is not
me saying this this is in page number
210 10. Yeah. He says this. Look,
some people uh the more that the the the
proving method or the method of proving
whatever it is you're trying to prove
was longer and slightly more ambiguous
and has more premises, then it was more
beneficial to them. Yeah. Listen to what
he says.
Because this individual has become used
to
looking at a long analytic kind of here
literally means to analyze something
logically, right?
And
basically in very sophisticated things
if the is very small in terms of or very
limited in terms of his premises is a
premise a logical premise and he's using
the language of the philosopher here
using the language of of the
so he's not going against the language
or something which is very um clear to
see
he's not happy with that. He's not
content with that. It doesn't satisfy
his satiate his philosophical if you
like curiosity.
Yeah. But he didn't say philosophical
just in case anyone wants to.
This individual you should use with them
the logical and calam approach.
So exactly. So it's it's not one shoe
fits all.
Yes. Exactly that. We're not saying that
everybody
and and that's exactly what we do
exactly that look is very clear he's
saying if these
which are go against the Quran and then
we should not use them
and there are some things that he
mentioned in his if you read his on this
like for example he mentions very
clearly which like for example there's
something called
and there's six types of which he does
not like he thinks they go against the
Quran and he mentions only one that is
plausible and by the way for more
information you know you're in contact
with him isn't it
he's actually done a sound cloud which
we'll put in the description box he's
done the whole description of and he's
written a book called
uh who we he goes into what goes against
the Quran and what doesn't right so he
filters it like that and people have
been filtering like this we're not
saying that everything is okay
like for example there's a called yeah
this was not liked by it was not even a
good anyways we don't even use it in da
we use a contingency argument We use
arguments which Ibamia did not oppose.
And we've got like the the small book
that I've written cosmological
arguments. I've actually got
one segment of Ibamia and I translate
exactly what Ibamia says about this and
you can see this free of charge on the
Salam website actually.
Oh
yeah, we've we've translated them. We
put it on the Salam website.
We'll put the link there
and we can put the link there as well.
So all of those things haven't been
said. The basic rule of thumb is if it
doesn't go against the Quran and Sunnah
then you cannot say it's haram. Okay,
it's as simple as that. Iban Tamir did
not share your view, okay, on um
anti-rational discourse or anti-
philosophical discourse. He just did
not. It would be false to say that he
did, okay? And the way that the Salaf
used the word calam was in reference to
adopting an ideology from outside or
from some um a framework from outside
and putting it into the Islamic and
using it for to understand. We say this
is false.
This is where the J and the were wrong
because they used it to understand Islam
and they were wrong to do so. We're not
using it to mix it with mis.
We have a pure un unadulterated
unfiltered perfect. The dean is perfect.
It doesn't need anything.
We just use this to bring people into
the dean.
Yes.
We don't use it as to try and s out what
is right and wrong in the dean.
This is very clear. What is right and
wrong is what Allah and the messenger
told us. And this is the reality of the
situation.
Exactly. So brothers and sisters, you
know, the reason what one of the reasons
I think it's very important for you to
do this video is because to show people
because what people do is they get this
and they run with it. And what they do
then they attack people because they
themselves do not know because because
they're like, "Oh, but he said, but do
you know what philosophy is?" No. What
are you doing? And this causes fitna.
I'm being honest. It's it's it's
actually um you know, it's it what's the
word? I forgot the word. You know, you
need to take responsibility. But who
come out there and you have a platform,
you need to take responsib.
And they have no understanding. All
they're doing is just causing a fit
between each other. You can't use it.
You can't. You're limiting the daer.
You're limiting it massively.
Massively. Yeah.
But it's like they're paralyzing us.
Would you respect? It's like, let me
tell you what it's like. So, sorry. Let
Exactly. Tell me if you if you think is
First of all, I would love to see these
brothers do a demonstration of what they
say. Like, I would love to see them
actually go out and speak to atheists on
their on their method. Because the thing
is, if you try and use the Quran to
prove the Quran, you're doing something
circular arguments. So, all they're
telling us to do is go and do circular
arguments. Maybe it doesn't matter for
them. Go do circular arguments. Bro, it
will cause you. I'll tell you if we use
their understanding,
we'll be they'll be up mortas. We'll be
giving birth to mutas like it's happy
days.
They think it's okay. But the the fact
of the matter is you haven't tried what
you're saying and you can't try what
you're saying. And Ibia doesn't doesn't
say what you're saying.
Look, go and do what you're saying. Show
us a physical demonstration of using
your circular arguments of using the
Quran to prove the Quran. Please go and
do that and show us what you mean by the
da that you're talking about without
philosophy and without logic and without
calam and without all those things,
especially to atheists. And that is the
that is the context. Go and do that
because we have not seen a successful
model of you doing that. Speak talk is
cheap. Go and do it and show us that
actually it's worked in your favor or
not. In reality, with all due respect,
they should be publicizing what we're
doing because it's
it's for some people to be doing these
things. They should be publicizing it.
They should be funding it. They should
be happy with it because
we meaning it's it's obligatory upon
some segment of the community.
Otherwise, all the community will be
sinful.
They would be sinful if we weren't doing
what we're doing. If and
they believe they're sinful, if they
promote us, no, they don't get it. This
is the problem. When you have a
segmented
understanding with ahistorical and uh
decontextualized approach to the Salaf
and bro, with all due respect, if this
is their approach to something as menial
as the word calam being used and
philosophy being used in literature,
imagine now are we meant to trust these
people with
but but this is what I'm saying. This is
why it all comes back to bro speaking
about matters you're not qualified to
and the havoc that you cause in all
areas. If you're doing this with this
issue, my gosh, what have you been doing
for the past 20 30 years?
Yeah, exactly man. We we all meant to be
our interpreters of the salaf, right?
And if you don't understand the
difference between oh the word the usage
of the word calam here and the
philosophy is different in these
contexts. You don't have to
contextualize like that
then now you expect us now when you do
of this person or this person's off the
manager. Now we are we are meant to
follow this. No, certainly not.
You know what I mean? Come on, let's be
honest, man.
So guys, I think generally speaking, we
will not accept being paralyzed in the
da for no reason
and definitely we have to we've done
videos to non-Muslims showing them that
our religion is a religion of
rationality. I mean Allah says in the
Quran many say and they know this and
they would agree with this no doubt. Do
you not reason? I mean I mean if we if
we the Quran says
bring your evidences if you're truthful.
It's as if we're telling them to bring
our evidences but we have no evidence.
Yeah. And all of this is nonsense. And
to be honest with you, we should uh this
is something which is uh left for the
ultra-conservative scripturalists. But
we do need to sort our own house. We put
it in order before we speak to the the
world. And this video is an example of
that. We cannot deny that these people
do exist in our midst and we do need to
educate them just like we need to
educate non-Muslims on these matters as
well.
That was brilliant man. Thank you. That
clarified a lot of things for me and
it's it's given me more com comfort
knowing I can carry on using my
contingency argument. Uh
not just that but almost infinite
regress
cosmological argument is not all of
these things are not against the in fact
the actually the of it theel of it is
the n itself. the of these arguments as
were they created from nothing or they
themselves they created themselves.
Yeah. Well, I'll be honest. I feel like
someone tied my hand and you just cut it
open. Thanks for that.
Alhamdulillah. And I hope everyone feels
the same way. This is not by the way to
say everyone should go and study
philosophy. No, we're not saying this.
You go and study Quran and Sunnah. Okay.
And if if you need a certain argument to
get you out of a certain
then there are some people organizations
like Sapiens, like
which basically try and do that for you.
Brilliant. Sapiens is absolut as well
brothers and sisters. Um yeah that's the
information and Ramadan they should be
giving fundraising and helping
Ramadan. Yeah, please. Yes,
please. Sapiens, support Sapiens, our
Salam campaign started in if you want.
Brilliant organizations. May Allah bless
you guys. Till next time, brothers and
sisters.